- Pour une troisièmee e e e e es
de manifestants ont brûlé
des poubelles et des voitures.
- C'est la guerre,
rien à fous's's's's's's's's's'st
sanitaire et à la vaccination
obligatoire des travailleurs
de la santé imposés par
le goudepuis le 15 novembre.
Une approche avec des relents
colonialistes, selon eux.
- On en a marre d'obéir
- On a l'impression d'être
les déchets de la métropole.
Et, ça suffit.
- Aussitôt nettoyées,
sont érigées.
Se faufiler entre deu
carcasses de voitures calcinées
fait maintenant partieesesesesee
quoi.
- C'est-à-dire?
- On fait pas une grève
comme ça.ieieieieieieieieieieieé
vandalisés et pillés, dont
ce supermarché.
- ils ont attrapé les caisses.
Ils l'ont tirée. Ils ont pris du
champagne. Ensuite, ils ont été
au niveau du magasin, ils ont
un peu de tout. Ils ont fait des
courses, quoi, en fin de c
- Conséquence :
l'approvisionnement en
paralyse la Guadeloupe.
Destination normalprprprprisée
par de nombreux voyageurs, comme
raconte cette franco-québécoise
CÉCILE LEQUEN, résidente de
Saint-, , , , , Guadeloupe
- J'ai dû aller à l'aéroport
vendredi, pour justement ramener
son vol pour Montréal et on a
blblblblbloquées à plusieurs
reprises par des barrages et
par des manifestants cagouléndnd
ses assises chez une partie
du personnel soignant, suspendus
parce qu'ils refusent
d'être vaccinés
- Si vous permettez, c'est
un choix. Et qu'on respecte
mon choix.
- Et auprès de ceux
attention à la jeunesse,
l'éducation et
aux infrastructures
de première nécessité.
- L'accès à l'eau potable, c'est
un droit.nsnsnsnsnsnsnsnsnsnsnùe
la population vit encore sous
le seuil de la pauvreté.
SÉBASTIEN LECORNU
- La violence n'a pas
sa place sur le territoire
de la République, en Guadeloupe
comme ailleurs.
dans son territoire outre-mer.
250 policiers et gendarmes
dont 50 des forces spéciales
du GIGN et du Raid, ont été
une colère qui s'étend
en Martinique, aus
Ici, Gabrielle Proulx,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.